[Musique]
sous nos pieds se cache un véritable
trésor des milliards de mètres cubes
d'eau douce où sont prélevés près des
deux tiers de l'eau potable consommée en
France
ces nappes d'eau souterraines
constituent aujourd'hui un enjeu
stratégique de première importance mais
comment fonctionne-t-elle
l'eau s'évapore au dessus des océans
revient s'infiltrer dans la terre quand
il pleut ou quand il neige et forme une
nappe tant qu'il pleut le niveau de la
nappe monte pendant l'été la chaleur va
provoquer une évaporation et les plantes
vont utiliser l'eau qui est sous la
terre alors le niveau de la nappe baisse
et le niveau des cours d'eau où elle se
jette diminue aussi
[Musique]
Marie pété Natti est la spécialiste
française des nappes d'eau souterraines
au BRGM le bureau des recherches
géologiques et minières
c'est notre stock les nappes d'eau
souterraines c'est là où on va pouvoir
préserver la ressource parce que elle se
situe sous nos pieds et ça permet de
d'avoir un stock d'eau utilisable pour
différents usages c'est primordial de
les préserver et de les étudier pour
savoir comment elle se recharge et
comment au futur elles vont évoluer dans
le temps
pour observer la nappe phréatique de
Beauce qui s'étale sur près de 10 000
kilomètres carrés les scientifiques ont
creusé un gigantesque puis de 20 mètres
de profondeur cette plateforme unique
est une opportunité pour acquérir des
connaissances sur les 20 milliards de
mètres cubes d'eau de la plus grande
réserve française
la recherche et les citoyens il faut
qu'elle servent à aider
toutes les toutes les parties prenantes
à réfléchir cette transition et il est
utile pour tout le monde on parle bien
sûr de la sobriété et d'autres choses
mais la transition écologique et les
fondamentale
[Musique]
surveillez la qualité des eaux
souterraines c'est aussi le travail
quotidien de l'Agence de l'Eau Loire
Bretagne qui effectue 700 prélèvements
par an sur son territoire nous sommes au
château d'eau de bacon dans le Loiret
Damien gabion spécialiste des eaux
souterraines introduit une sonde pour
mesurer le niveau de l'eau dans la nappe
phréatique de Beauce 45 mètres plus bas
le dérèglement climatique va faire qu'on
va avoir des précipitations en moins de
l'ordre 10 à 30% les débits des cours
d'eau également vont baisser donc
évidemment on va rentrer dans une
période où les précipitations sont
moindres l'évaporation plus importante
est donc des niveaux de nappes
effectivement qui peuvent être par année
problématiques
le manque d'eau n'est pas le seul sujet
d'inquiétude le taux de nitrates et lui
aussi préoccupant sur la map de brousse
on est dans les ordres de 40 50 mg par
litre parfois un peu plus parfois un peu
moins donc effectivement on est dans ces
ordres là une eau voilà qui est lié aux
activités agricoles à l'époque on
retrouve également des pesticides et des
molécules de dégradation par exemple de
la trazine on retrouve ici de la trazine
des études un herbicide qui a été
interdit depuis 2003 donc encore une
fois on retrouve aujourd'hui des
molécules qui ne sont plus utilisées
aujourd'hui mais qui étaient utilisées
il y a à peu près une vingtaine d'années
et ça n'est pas tout un rapport rendu
public le mois dernier dresse un constat
inquiétant sur la présence des polluants
éternels les fameux pie face dans les
eaux souterraines les scientifiques
pressent la France d'agir sans tarder
contre les risques sanitaires liés à ces
substances dans l'eau potable ce nouveau
polluant alors l'épiface ce sont des
molécules extrêmement solides et
résistantes qu'on va retrouver par
exemple pour confectionner nos poils
antiadhésives ou du téflon ou des
vêtements imperméables donc c'est des
substances qu'on retrouve dans notre
quotidien et qui ont ce dégradant vont
se retrouver dans l'environnement et
donc on commence à les analyser depuis
quelques années des substances qui
peuvent être effectivement toxiques pour
la même pour l'environnement
de nombreuses études ont révélé que ces
polluants pouvaient provoquer des
cancers et perturber les systèmes
hormonaux et immunitaires l'idée c'est
de ne plus les utiliser et trouver des
molécules de substitution voire des
pratiques différentes pour éviter
d'utiliser ces molécules il y a certaine
molécules qui vont avoir des temps de
vie très différents dans ces dans ces
milieux naturels mais effectivement les
très persistants ils vont rester on va
les retrouver longtemps et l'idée c'est
de c'est de diminuer leur concentration
à la source et donc dans diminuer
l'usage voir de ne plus les utiliser
en France si on estima environ 6500 les
nappes d'eau souterraines répertoriées
il en reste encore un grand nombre à
découvrir ce matin-là près de la rivière
Lille dans le Périgord se prépare une
opération un peu spéciale Olivier
cabaret hydrogéologue au BRGM a donné
rendez-vous à une équipe de dronistes
d'aujourd'hui on va essayer de faire un
petit survol là du cours d'eau l'idée
c'est de voir les échanges entre la
nappe d'eau et puis la rivière
des nappes souterraines était une
température constante autour de 13
degrés contrairement à celle des
rivières qui varient entre 3 degrés
l'hiver après de 25 degrés l'été une
différence de température
détectée par la caméra thermique du
drone tu peux faire le focus sur juste à
la valve du pont ici là sur la petite
sortie le long ouais voilà c'est ça
les équipes du BRGM travaillent depuis
plusieurs années à la découverte de
nouveaux gisements d'eau on s'est aperçu
on regarde les différents débits qu'on a
des mesures de débit qu'on a fait sur ce
cours d'eau en particulier mais qui
avait des variations qu'on n'arrivait
pas à expliquer seulement par des
résurgences ou des sorties des affluents
connus donc on s'est dit qu'il y avait
sûrement des arrivées supplémentaires et
on s'est dit bah pourquoi pas mettre en
œuvre cette méthodologie pour visualiser
plus précisément ces contributions des
nappes profondes au profit du cours
d'eau
[Musique]
en une heure le drone a scanné environ
200 mètres du cours d'eau
[Musique]
sans attendre l'équipe va procéder à une
première analyse des résultats
survol le cours d'eau en amont on passe
le pont et on voit effectivement les
premières arrivées d'eau chaude dont on
n'avait pas spécialement connaissance
ici sur la berge gauche
et ici voilà là on retrouve la source
qu'on connaît
on voit bien un contraste de température
entre les eaux chaudes
et puis après ça vient se mélanger on a
le panache de mélange et on a d'autres
arrivées là parce que c'est encore plus
chaud ici
ce qui est encore une expérience
fournira des informations précieuses
pour l'avenir
là c'est vraiment de tester une approche
méthodologique pour nous permettre
derrière de dézoomer d'avoir une
approche un peu plus générale pour mieux
comprendre l'état de la ressource en eau
et pouvoir évaluer la réaction des
nappes dans le futur au changement
climatique
retour au siège de l'Agence de l'Eau
Loire Bretagne à Orléans dans le bureau
de Damien gabion
l'hydrogéologue a analysé les résultats
des prélèvements effectuer lors de sa
tournée la collecte de toutes les
données du bassin Loire Bretagne se
retrouve sur cette carte où les zones
rouges sont celles ou l'eau souterraine
et polluée
la proportion de nappe en bon état et
aujourd'hui de l'ordre de 50%, 50% des
abdos souterraines qui sont en bon état
50% qui sont donc dégradés il y a 10 ans
on était à peu près sur ces mêmes
proportions
donc même s'il y a quelques paramètres
qui ce qui s'améliorent globalement on a
encore du mal du mal à atteindre les
objectifs
demandés par l'Europe
les eaux souterraines sont une ressource
vitale aujourd'hui souillée par
l'activité humaine si on doit baisser
les prélèvements dans une nappe d'eau
souterraine ça veut dire qu'on remet en
cause toutes les activités humaines qui
sont liées à l'eau et finalement toutes
nos activités sont liées à l'eau toute
une aptitude l'activité économique
l'alimentation d'eau potable
l'irrigation parfois des cultures ça
remet en cause finalement l'ensemble de
la société dans ses usages en premier
lieu c'est la sobriété qui prime
toujours réduire la consommation mais il
y a cette solution qui existe c'est à
dire
d'artificiellement recharger une nappe à
partir d'une autre surface à partir
d'autres pluies voir d'eau usées ça se
fait dans le monde depuis des années en
Californie en Israël on a des exemples
de ces recharges de nappe très efficaces
pour un usage futur
[Musique]
recharger la ressource en eau c'est le
projet expérimenté sur la Garonne le
fleuve alimente en eau potable un
million 400 000 personnes et les
exploitations agricoles du secteur
pour remédier à la sécheresse estivale
qui s'aggrave l'idée est de récupérer le
stocker l'hiver dans un canal à 60 km de
Toulouse sous terre dans la nappe
phréatique elle va progresser de
quelques mètres chaque jour et rejoindra
la Garonne en été quand le fleuve est à
sec une première en Europe menée par le
BRGM et le département de Haute-Garonne
on expire vraiment pouvoir stocker entre
5 et 10 millions de mètres cubes quand
on pense aux fameuses bassines qui
feront 600
000 mètres cubes on boit le potentiel de
stockage dans dans ses nappes mais après
c'est un phénomène naturel donc il faut
l'observer
l'expérimentation livrera ses premiers
résultats dans 4 ans
ça c'est des terrains qui sont
particulièrement perméables donc l'eau
en s'écoulant elle va saturer et elle va
s'infiltrer au fond et sur les côtés et
progressivement rejoindre la nappe
mais pour les écologistes mettre en
place des systèmes pour continuer à
offrir de l'eau en période de sécheresse
empêche tout changement de comportement
l'humain a beaucoup artificialisé
beaucoup perturbé beaucoup dénaturés et
aujourd'hui il essaye aller dans l'autre
sens de peut-être trouver des solutions
de venir réintervenir en pensant qu'on
va maîtriser la nature alors que si déjà
on laissait la nature faire et en lui
redonner toute sa capacité ce serait
bien encore une fois il faut apprendre à
voir systématiquement une vision de
gestion intégrée de la ressource avec
tous les acteurs du territoire pour
pouvoir éviter d'en arriver à ces
conditions extrêmes de
pénurie totale sur sur certaines
communes donc c'est faisable moi j'y
crois bien sûr
les nappes phréatiques représentent
aujourd'hui
99% des réserves d'eau douce de la
planète
un gisement capital qui a conduit l'ONU
à l'ancien cri d'alarme pour que tous
les états deviennent les protecteurs des
eaux souterraines
[Musique]